c'était le 17 novembre 2018 de la france
vivait le premier rassemblement initié
par les gilets jaunes la police
recensait alors 280 ming français dans
les rues des manifestants qui a dénoncé
la hausse du prix du carburant et plus
généralement la cherté de la vie le
mouvement a perduré tous les samedis
dans le pays avant de s'essouffler
l'heure des restrictions qu'ovide
aujourd'hui mobilisation nationale pour
marquer l'anniversaire des trois ans
cortèges dans toute la france dont la
capitale le cortège parisien justement
on retrouve notre reporter nadège
abderrazak
nadège bonjour alors est ce que le calme
est revenu
[Applaudissements]
absolument pas amira situation toujours
aussi tendue que depuis le départ de
cette manifestation depuis le boulevard
de bercy vous le voyez est derrière nous
un des agents de la brave de la brigade
de répression de l'action violente
viennent tout juste d'arriver pour et
bien apporter du soutien à leurs
collègues crs et gendarmes qui est
visiblement vent un peu de mal à assurer
le maintien depuis le début de cette
manifestation alors c'est ses forces de
l'ordre sont en train de répondre
systématiquement par des tirs de gaz
lacrymogènes aux projectiles qu'ils
reçoivent on a dû mobilier urbain des
poubelles qui sont en train d'être
retourné incendiée est dégradée
également donc situation extrêmement
tendue peut-être
une affluence également record en depuis
des mois puisque ils sont plusieurs
milliers de gilet jaune avoir fait le
déplacement aujourd'hui pour ce
troisième anniversaire du mouvement
alors les revendications elles sont
elles mêmes que depuis le début du
mouvement
ils demandent une baisse du prix du
carburant et une demande plus de justice
sociale fiscale et environnementale mise
en place du ricain du référendum
d'initiative citoyenne et puis d'autres
revendications des points de
contestation se sont ajoutées avec
l'apparition de la crise sanitaire et le
manifeste pour la plupart d'entre eux
contre eux ne passent là ni terre et
contre l'obligation vaccinale pour
certaines professions donc que
l'ambiance est extrêmement tendue vous
l'entendez derrière nous à ses agents de
la brave dame brigade de répression de
l'action violente son se font huer et
siffler et insulter par un certain
manifestants des agents d'un bras qui
pour l'instant ne réplique pas un
restaurant un retrait donc le parcours
continue son 1,1 avancé cet après-midi
dans les rues de paris mais on sent que
l attention est extrêmement impalpable
avec des gilets jaunes qui continuent de
scander des slogans hostiles à la police
vous l'entendez
réputé slogan également hostiles au
gouvernement de jean castex hostile
également à emmanuel macron el-assad
politique voilà ce que l'on peut dire
pour l'instant sur cette manifestation
consacrée au troisième anniversaire des
gille et joli